MOMENTS AGO, THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE RELEASED MORE
TESTIMONY AND EVIDENCE ABOUT THE
INTERNAL DEBATE THAT WENT ON AT
THE WHITE HOUSE OVER WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD SAY AND
WE'RE LEARNING WOULD NOT SAY IN
HIS REMARKS THE DAY AFTER THE
SIEGE ON THE CAPITOL.
OUR CORRESPONDENT IS LIVE ON
CAPITOL HILL WITH THIS.
MELANIE, WHAT ARE YOU LEARNING?
>> Reporter: IN A SIGN OF JUST
HOW MUCH INFORMATION THE SELECT
COMMITTEE HAS GATHERED, THEY
HAVE RELEASED NEW VIDEO CLIPS
THAT HAD TO BE LEFT ON THE
RUTTING ROOM FLOOR.
THIS NEW DEPOSITION FOOTAGE
FOCUSES ON THE ROSE GARDEN
SPEECH THAT TRUMP GAVE JANUARY
7th.
WE KNEW THAT HE STRUGGLED WITH
THAT SPEECH, HE STRUGGLED TO
CONDEMN THE VIOLENCE.
AND WE ARE NOW LEARNING THAT
TRUMP ACTUALLY SCRATCHED OFF A
NUMBER OF KEY LINES FROM THAT
INITIAL DRAFT SPEECH.
TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT ELSE HE'S
WILLING TO SAY AND NOT SAY THE
DAY AFTER THE RIOTS.
>> IN MY VIEW, HE NEEDED TO
EXPRESS VERY CLEARLY THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO COMMITTED VIOLENT
ACTS, WENT INTO THE CAPITOL, DID
WHAT THEY DID, SHOULD BE
PROSECUTED AND SHOULD BE
ARRESTED.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE HERE THAT HE
CROSSED OUT THAT HE WAS
DIRECTING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO ENSURE
LAWBREAKERS ARE PROSECUTED UNDER
THE FULL EXTENT OF THE LAW,
LEGAL CONSEQUENCES MUST BE SWIFT
AND FIRM.
DO YOU KNOW WHY HE WANTED THAT
CROSSED OUT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> Reporter: THE COMMITTEE IS
PLANNING ADDITIONAL HEARINGS IN
SEPTEMBER.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SAY THEY ARE
GOING TO SEND THE NEXT MONTH
PURSUING NEW LEADS AND TALKING
TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES.
ONE OUTSTANDING ISSUE IS WHETHER
TO SUBPOENA THE WIFE OF SUPREME
COURT JUSTICE CLARENCE THOMAS,
WHO WAS EMAILING TRUMP ALLIES.
LIZ CHENEY SAID THE COMMITTEE IS
PREPARED TO GO THAT ROUTE IF SHE
DOES NOT COME IN VOLUNTARILY.
SO AUGUST IS SHAPING UP TO BE A
VERY BUSY MONTH.
THE WAY THAT ELAINE LAURIA PUT
IT THIS WEEKEND, THE FLOOD GATES
HAVE OPENED SINCE THE
INVESTIGATION STARTED.
THEY STARTED WITH THEIR HEARINGS
AND THEY'RE GETTING SO MANY MORE
WITNESSES COMING FORWARD TO
TESTIFY.
WHERE DOES THIS ALL GO FROM HERE
AFTER, YOU KNOW, WHAT WE HAVE
LEARNED WITH THAT, ESPECIALLY IN
THE BIG LAST HEARING.
WE KNOW THERE'S MORE COMING.
WHERE IS IT GOING?
>> WHAT'S BEEN SO INTERESTING
ABOUT THESE HEARINGS IS THAT IT
HASN'T BEEN ABOUT THE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
IT'S BEEN ABOUT THE EVIDENCE
THEY HAVE DISCLOSED,
PARTICULARLY THE VIDEO EVIDENCE
OF PEOPLE'S DEPOSITIONS.
AT FIRST IT SEEMED LIKE IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO GET PEOPLE TO
TESTIFY LIVE.
THEY REALIZED IT'S BETTER TO
HAVE PEOPLE ON VIDEO SO IT CAN
BE EDITED AND CONTROLLED BETTER
BY THE COMMITTEE.
WE'LL SEE MORE OF THAT.
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE A LOT OF
AVENUES OPEN TO THE COMMITTEE.
THEY SAY THAT PEOPLE HAVE COME
OUT OF THE WOODWORK TO TESTIFY
AND COOPERATE BECAUSE OF THE
QUALITY OF THE HEARINGS.
I DON'T KNOW IN WHICH AREA, BUT
THERE IS A LOT THERE, AND THERE
WILL BE MORE HEARINGS IN
SEPTEMBER.
TODAY THE PANEL HAS BEEN
CLEARED.
THE COMMITTEE SHOWING HOW
RELUCTANT, HOW VERY RELUCTANT
DONALD TRUMP WAS TO SPEAK OUT
THE DAY AFTER THE INSURRECTION.
>> DO YOU RECOGNIZE THE
HAND
HANDWRITING?
>> IT LOOKS LIKE MY FATHER'S
HANDWRITING.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE, HERE, THAT HE
CROSSED OUT THAT HE WAS
DIRECTING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO ENSURE ALL
LAWBREAKERS ARE PROSECUTED TO
THE FULLEST EXTENT OF THE LAW.
WE MUST SEND A CLEAR MESSAGE,
NOT WITH MERCY BUT WITH JUSTICE.
LEGAL CONSEQUENCES MUST BE SWIFT
AND FIRM.
DO YOU KNOW WHY HE WANTED THAT
CROSSED OUT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> WAS THE IMPLICATION THAT THE
PRESID
PRESIDENT WAS RELUCTANT TO GIVE
THAT SPEECH?
>> YEAH.
>> LET'S GET STRAIGHT TO CAPITOL
HILL AND CNN'S RYAN NOBAN NOBLE.
WE MAY BE DOING THINGS BEHIND
THE SCENES, ACCORDING TO THE
COMMITTEE, BUT A LITTLE IN YOUR
FACE FOR DONALD TRUMP.
>> Reporter: I'M TOLD THE
ORIGINAL PLAN WHEN THEY WENT
THROUGH THEIR FIRST REHEARSAL,
THE HEARING COULD HAVE LASTED AS
LONG AS 4 HOURS.
THEY KNEW THAT WASN'T PALATABLE
FOR A PRIMETIME AUDIENCE.
THEY PARRED IT BACK, ALMOST HALF
OF WHAT THEY PLANNED.
THAT VIDEO IS PART OF IT.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THE
POINT THEY'RE TRYING TO MAKE OF
DONALD TRUMP'S MOTIVATION ON
JANUARY 7th, THE DAY AFTER THE
RIOT TOOK PLACE AT THE CAPITOL.
LISTEN TO WHAT HIS WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL, PAT CIPOLLONE, HAD TO
SAY ABOUT IT.
>> HE NEEDED TO EXPRESS VERY
CLEARLY THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
COMMITTED VIOLENT ACTS WENT INTO
CAPITOL, DID WHAT THEY DID,
SHOULD BE PROSECUTED AND SHOULD
BE ARRESTED.
THAT NEEDED TO BE STATED.
THEY DID NOT REPRESENT HIM OR
THE -- HIS POLITICAL VIEWS IN
ANY FORM OR FASHION.
>> SO THE QUESTION NOW IS, WHERE
DOES THE COMMITTEE GO NEXT?
THEY'VE HINTED THEY WANT TO
REACH OUT TO MEMBERS OF THE
TRUMP CABINET WHO WERE IN AND
AROUND THE WHITE HOUSE ON
JANUARY 6th, WHAT THEIR
MOTIVATIONS WERE FOR STAYING OR
GOING.
MANY RESIGNED IN THE WAKE OF
JANUARY 6th.
THEN THERE IS THE QUESTION OF
GINNI THOMAS.
WE KNOW SHE WAS IN CONTACT WITH
PEOPLE LIKE MARK MEADOWS AND
JOHN EASTMAN, THE CONSERVATIVE
LAWYER.
WHAT THE WKMIET TE COMMITTEE IS
WITH IS HOW INVOLVED SHE WAS IN
CERTIFYING THE ELECTION AND
WHETHER HER HUSBAND WAS INVOLVED
IN THAT.
THE COMMITTEE ISN'T READY TO
MAKE THAT DECLARATION OR TAKE IT
THAT FAR.
THEY HAVE A HOST OF OTHER THINGS
THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
MAYBE BE A BIT OF A BIGGER
PRIORITY THAN GINNI THOMAS RIGHT
NOW.
AS WE'VE SEEN FROM THE BEGINNING
OF THIS INVESTIGATION, THEY WILL
GO WHEREVER IT LEADS.
IF IT ENDS UP WITH GINNI THOMAS,
THEY'RE NOT AFRAID TO GO THERE.